in the previous video I have shown you
how to normalize the data that is
derived from the shRNA library screen in
the series of the videos I'm going to
show you later that will include okay
how you can actually identify the hit
based on those data in general there are
three approaches that normally people of
researcher will use to identify the hit
from the RNA I library screen first of
all you can actually use the z-score cut
off to actually determine whether the
particular knockdown of a particular
genes is significantly associated with a
phenotype that you want or you can also
use a statistical method called
redundant si RNA activity analysis or in
short RSA analysis and similarly you can
use another method which is called the
RNA I gene and Richmond ranking or rigor
analysis in the following videos I'm
going to show you in detail how you can
actually use these three approaches to
identify the heat from any of the RNA I
library screen data okay so one way to
actually identify the hisses actually
based on your C score if you look at the
excel sheet that you have prepared
previously this is basically the C score
that you obtain from the normalized data
now what you can see here however is
that okay for one particular gene for
example in this case here the ANPR one
genes actually targeted by several SH
RNA so what we need to do basically is
to consolidate all this different sh RNA
and to see what is the effect of
knocking down this particular gene has
in terms of the cancer cell survival so
one way to do it
basically to count how many sh RNA in
the particular how many shrna that
hockey the particular genes can induce
the type of phenotype that we wanted and
in this case here the phenotype that we
want is actually two
reduce the cell proliferation and
basically we are looking for the C score
that are in the negative value the more
negative it is they indicate that okay
the shRNA was actually depleted in the
pool genome-wide shRNA and suggests that
they are actually less shRNA in the
particular pool so basically what you
can do is you can decide to cut off
whether you want to select for those
genes that are actually - more than
minus 1.5 or - less than 2 and so forth
you can decide that cut off but before
you do that so what I'm going to do is
basically I'm going to create another
excel sheet playing here and I'm going
to populate all this information the
first thing I want to do is basically I
want to get all the the gene and also
the shRNA into one column here and then
I will labor this this is all basically
these are all the genes that are covered
under the current SH our new dataset so
next what I need to do is basically I'm
going to filter it for example for PSP
c3 I'm only interested in the shRNA that
are less than or equal to say minus 2 so
and then I'm going to copy this list
okay into the excel sheet here so then
you can then label this column as one
second is still running so you can then
they put a column according to the cell
lines so this one out this is what you
you can do basically okay that's good so
I'm just going to copy this this is the
PX PC lie and that's similarly I'm going
to filter for less a CF Pack 1 so again
it's less than equals to minus 2 so
again the cutoff you can decide what
kind of your words if you want my
- or if you won - tree so that is fine
so actually there's no what you called
it that there's no absolute card also
some people use - - some people use -
three and so forth but personally I
prefer to use - - so that would give you
quite a quite a number of heat and in
the same time it is also quite stringent
as well so now so what you can do is
basically you can repeat this exercise
and of course student remember to do
remember to label yourself as well so if
if well you can do this with all the
individual cell lines so once you have
done basically then you will actually
get excel sheet something that something
looked like this with all the cell lines
and also with all the shrna Jin his that
are being identified in in in the data
set okay once you have populated or the
cell line and also the hits for each of
the shrna you will get a table something
like this so the next thing what I'm
going to do is basically I'm going to
create a master list of the genes so by
copying this into a separate column oops
sorry I think I'm just going to copy
this into a separate column here okay
and what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to remove those that are actually
duplicate well remember okay why you
have you have more than one entry for
SAT here and one genes that is because
there's multiple shrna targeting that
genes but for me to actually consolidate
I just want to know basically when you
target that gene what is the effect so
I'm not going to consolidate all those
effects so I'm not interested in the
effect of the individual shrna but I'm
more interested in to the effect of
knocking down of the particular genes so
here what I'm going to do is I'm going
to remove the duplicate so that you will
then get a list of the the master list
of the genes that is covered in the gene
in this library for example now after
you remove
order to placate you laughs basically
about 3,400 genes that is being targeted
in in this study okay okay so the next
step what I'm going to do is basically
I'm going to okay count how many Essex
RNA in this place are actually match
into this this master lease here in
other words basically I want to know how
many sh RNA that come out to give the
phenotype that I wanted okay within a
particular cell line so to do that so
I'm going to label this hater here as
all shrna and then you will use the
command count the order formula count if
so then the range you can select the
range here okay the whole range and then
equals to this cell here so then it will
return back then you will get three here
how do you get three here it's because
okay under this column that is three
entry with the gene name a LPP l2 so you
have two here and is another one here
all right so now if you copy this whole
string if I'm just going to lock the
column so if I'm going to copy this
whole string here I'm sorry
copy this part here and then all the way
to the bottom of the list and you can
basically see is that okay ATM in the
whole library they are all together 20
shRNA titanica ATM and so forth okay now
let's look at how about the cell line so
how many of the shrna that come out as a
hit so basically we just copied this
cell and then you put it across so then
then it will actually match so for
example in this column how many of okay
how many of the gene in this column have
a match with this cell here and answer
is that is zero so that
instead well in BSP c3 none of the shrna
that targeted a LPP to actually give a C
score that is less than 0.2 you can copy
this all the way down as well so for
example in a and B are one so then you
can see that okay that's one instances
that occur here that's why the count is
equal to one here so what you can do is
that then you can copy this formula so
across through the whole array so then
you can after that then you can actually
get a quick count of okay how many shrna
is actually came out as a hit okay sorry
I'm going to here so then now you can
see that okay so quite a lot okay that
that's how you can see okay how many
shrna that actually give you the z score
of minus two in all the sound lines that
you have okay by now you should have
this table here that show you how many
shRNA that could induce z score of less
than minus two in each of the cell lines
for example for SSX one basically they
are three out of the d3 shrna that gives
you C score of minus of less than minus
2 in the px PC tree so now the next
thing what I want to do is basically to
see to identify which shrna that I want
to identify for the hiss as a four
following study now by convention
basically to make sure that the
phenotype that I wanted actually a real
phenotype by convention basically you
need at least two independent shrna that
give rise to the same phenotype to
confirm is
activity so in this case here so those
SHR locate those heat for example a NPR
one only have one shRNA that give me the
phenotype that I wanted so they might
not be as strong compared to let's say
in these guys here which actually have
four shRNA that give rise to the same to
the phenotype they I wonder so what I'm
going to do now is basically to identify
the cut-off by using by defining the
heat as as in the genes that by
knockdown by at least two independent
shrna that gives me the z-score of
lessons -2 so what I'm going to do here
is basically I'm going to count across
all the cell lines how many okay cell
lines actually can give me at least two
shrna that that is considered as heat so
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to use again the formula count if so and
this will be the whole range from here
to here and the criteria would be more
or equals to two shRNA so and what you
can do here oops sorry forgot to put in
this one here okay here so you can see
here is that basically what it means
here is that for this ALP p LG knocked
down basically there is only one cell
line okay in this case here as a new
fourth hand that actually have have two
independent shrna that have less than
the z-score of lessons -2 so if you copy
this one all the way down basically then
you can actually if you give you the
list of of gene knockdown that will
induce the the phenotype in the
different cell lines for example you can
see that while this one here Bo p1 when
you knock down basically almost all the
cells affected there are 18 cell lines
at this of
affected except for as a new 410
basically so by doing this basically
then you can identify and prioritize
okay which which genes that you want to
look there for example or together here
you have how many cell - 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17 18 19 you have
all the 19 cell lines here so is there
oh that's quite interesting so there is
actually some of the genes when you
knocked out they can actually inhibit
the growth of all the cell lines and I
want to know what this gene is so I'm
going to filter it down and see which
one is it
it's a bit slow
you
you know that's a bit slow here so but
anyway so I hope that you roughly get
the sense of how this and this is much
work so next we will be moved into
another method oh here you go
so the result is here so now these are
the lists of the gene so this is quite
interesting this is the one that when
you knock down on at least two of the
shrna for that target these genes can
actually cause the growth eraser or
inhibitor cell proliferation in all the
pancreatic cancer cells and this will be
something that will be quite interesting
and you can use this as one of the heat
as well so it depends on what is a
cut-off that you want to use and you can
filter it accordingly
okay the analysis that you saw just now
are basically based on the cutoff
meaning that okay i just i'm just going
to interested to know how many shrna
that gives me to see less than minus two
okay for example now there's also
another way that you can look at it by
calculating the average of the stature
of each individual shrna they target a
particular gene so and to do that okay
you can create another column here if
you want to okay you can create two more
columns here all right so we just find
just now so what I'm going to do here is
basically I'm going to calculate the
average okay
but it's average see score that is
induced by knocking down of a LP pl2 for
example I'm going to use the formula
average if okay average if so then and
then you can actually see okay the first
thing you need to identify the range so
this is the range of the original
dataset which is basically looking at
the z-score here so and this will be the
the so called the range the range will
be this one here in the column see
okay and then your criteria will be to
match it to this cell and then I want
the number that I want to average it
basically located at this column okay so
and when you press ENTER and they will
tell you then okay 4px 4px pc3 the
average C score by knocking down your PP
- it's actually zero point four four
okay so you if you want you can cross
examine it but basically it should be
quite accurate so now so I'm going to
copy this cell and then to populate it
in each of the data column so by
basically locking the the range of this
one I don't have to lock it but yeah I
do need to lock this part here so now
you can see that if I'm going to copy
okay if this one is here then I also
need to lock this column as well yeah
now when you copy it down so then you
will get that if you copy across you can
see that well it will automatically
match it to the Cisco C column so this
is your this this is the column for the
gene symbol in the whole dataset and
then you also have them match it to D
this column here okay the AES I have
locked it okay and calculating the
z-score return would be at F column C it
automatically move across so now what I
can do here is basically I can just copy
the whole cell here and then I can and
go all the way down to the list
okay and that it wouldn't calculate the
average C score for each for each of the
cell lines following the knockdown of
the particular gene so this will be the
average of the C score that is from all
the shrna that have been used in the
library okay so now you have all the
average C score for each particular gene
the next thing would be the easiest okay
you can calculate the mean of the
z-score for all the cell lines okay by
you calculating the average across
basically go down the table so then you
can calculate this and again so if you
want to if you want to identify what
data heat so you can also base on the
average C score cutoff for example if I
want to look at only best 10 or equals
to minus 2 so what would be the genes
that could give me the average and C
score across all the cell lines with at
least minus 2c score so you can do this
type of anything say so this is one way
to look at the data set and identify the
hist using the C score so in the next
few videos I'm going to show you how you
can also use the other two method RSA
and also rego and how do you decide
which his methods are you going to use
so if you want to have the most
stringent analysis you can always use
the tree and if all the three methods
giving you the same list and those genes
that are identified by all the three
different methods then you will have a
higher confidence that they are actually
giving you a significant phenotype that
you wondered but of course a lot of the
papers is up to you some only UC score
some choose to use RSA only
so it really depends so there's no
absolute consensus what you need to do
so but basically this is one way is
based one way that I've shown you here
is basically by using the z-score okay
so that's all for this video so I will
show you in the next video on the other
methods as well thank you